foreign
we're going to take a new look
at this old family portrait you know
it's the one that many of us grew up
with and so you might say this is the
story of A Brave New prehistoric World a
story of cutting-edge Science and heated
debate about the evolution of our
species homo sapiens
to get us started here is a quick
timeline it was around six to eight
million years ago that humans and
chimpanzees branched off from a common
ancestor and from then it took about
another four million years for an
adventurous group of archaic humans
called Homo erectus or upright man to
leave Africa now this group spread
across a wide swath from
southern Europe to Eastern Asia and were
last seen at least according to the
fossil record about a hundred and eight
thousand years ago in Indonesia
that timing probably overlap with that
of early Homo sapiens but fossil
evidence seems to put them in different
Geographic locations so whether members
of the two groups ever met that is still
an open question now all of this was
going on in what archaeologists call the
middle to late Paleolithic a period that
has yielded stunning discoveries in just
the last decade we've learned that
between roughly a hundred thousand and
fifty thousand years ago at least six
other groups of early hominids walked
the Earth at the same time as Homo
sapiens the previously much maligned
neanderthals a group in Asia called the
Denise events at least three different
groups of hobbit-like humans in South
Africa homo naledi in Indonesia homo
floresiensis and in the Philippines homo
luzonensis
and recently we met a member of yet one
more group in China called homolongi
fondly referred to as Dragon man and it
turns out that's a compliment in North
America we also learned that a haunting
set of footprints in White Sands
National park likely belong to a group
of early humans who lived there before
the last glacial maximum or Ice Age
which is tens of thousands of years
before conventional wisdom placed human
arrival in the Americas
is it time to completely re-evaluate who
we are as a species what Have We
inherited from those long-lost ancestors
and what can they tell us about
ourselves
we are joined today by four researchers
whose approach to these issues come from
a variety of different perspectives and
who bring the tools of different
disciplines to Bear upon them joining us
from Vienna Thomas hayam professor of
evolutionary anthropology at the
University of Vienna from Doha Sheila
athrea a paleoanthropologist at Texas a
M's campus in Qatar joining us from
Jerusalem we have Vivian Sloan the head
of the ancient DNA Lab at Tel Aviv
University and from Cape Town South
Africa Rebecca Ackerman who is the
founding director of the human evolution
Research Institute at the University of
Cape Town welcome to you all thank you
so much for joining us there is
incredible amount of excitement in your
field rapid changes over the last 10
years so I'd like to start by asking
each of you what do you consider the
most exciting work that's happened being
right now in the study of human Origins
let's begin with Vivion just the ability
to recover DNA from archaic hominins
neanderthals Denise events I think is
very exciting it's something relatively
new only a couple of decades that we've
been able to do this and we can now do
this to the extent where we get data
from the entire Genome of individuals
that live tens and even hundreds of
thousands of years ago so I think
there's a lot to be discovered and it's
an exciting field to be in
Tom how about you what would you if you
were going to write the headline for the
for the globe mail or whatever your
favorite
newspaper is what would you say
um well I think Viviana has hit the nail
on the head as far as I'm concerned to
me the most exciting things over the
last decade or two has been the um the
Revolutionary information that we can
now glean from ancient genomics this
gives us the opportunity to look at the
the on the ground situation in terms of
the distribution of these various actors
that we have in the uh in the field of
human evolution Becky how about you
what's your take on that question
so my take is that I think the most
exciting thing is that it is showing us
everything that's happening in the field
is showing us how complex the origin of
humans is that it's not a simple
narrative and that we're not talking
about you know as you as you introduce
one group coming out and conquering
everybody else in fact it's a much more
sophisticated
um thing that's going on in this space
and related to that I think that's
allowing for the emergence of frankly
people paying attention to regions of
the world that they hadn't paid
attention to before and I think long
term that's going to be a really
important part of our increasing
understanding of these sort of complex
Origins Gila thoughts on that yeah I
would say it's a bit of what everyone
else has said so far
um which is that it's a combination of
um the research that's coming out of
areas that have historically been
underrepresented or or actively
marginalized and specifically I'm
thinking about east and south East Asia
but also the tools are getting better to
get information from the materials that
are
in environments that don't preserve very
well and so the work that viviane and
Tom do allows us to get information from
remains that historically we wouldn't
have been able to to get any information
from you know I have heard maybe this is
apocryphal but there was a time when
folks tried to date bones fossils by
licking them the tongue would stick to
the old ones and not to the new ones I I
presume we've gone beyond that
substantially by today maybe we can
start with
radiocarbon data I think many people are
familiar with that but just give us the
basics of that and then we can talk
about how you've been pressing that
field forward okay sure so um well
radiocarbon is um one of the most
important techniques that we have for
dating the archaeological past there are
some problems with it which we'll we'll
touch on but one of the main problems is
that it runs out at about 50 000 years
ago and that's that's sad because it's
just about that time that the late
period of human evolution becomes super
exciting we have to rely on on a on a
new range of other dating techniques
that include other types of isotopes
that we can use to measure and other
types of techniques that allow us to add
um to to the dating of of archaeological
sites because of course dating is
critical in archeology looking at you
know the presence and absence of humans
and their relationships with other types
of humans it's all predicated upon
having a robust chronology and we need
to know when things happened in the past
in order to understand why they have
happened and so radiocarbon and other
techniques are crucial in this in this
endeavor yeah sure now we've all seen
you know whole bones and skulls from
archaeological sites but I've seen
images of some of the samples that you
analyze and many look really tiny like
like this little chip off an old Pinky
bone and I gather that making things get
more challenging sometimes these samples
are actually contaminated with DNA from
other periods is that right
it's a big problem and it's been it's
been probably the biggest hurdle in
terms of the reliable application of
this method so if you take for example a
bone that's 50 000 years old and you
imagine contaminating it with modern
carbon that's in the soil for instance
that will produce a radiocarbon
measurement that's 13 000 years too
young
and so as we go back in time so the
bones and other samples get more prone
to this contamination signal and
contamination effect we have to use
quite sophisticated chemical methods to
clean up the samples that we want to
reliably date we have many many dates
that have been produced over the last 60
years that are unfortunately we now know
underestimates of the real age so so Tom
for many years now you've been studying
among other things Neanderthal sites
across Europe and parts of Asia and and
as I've read some of the research that
you and your colleagues have done in
these places it paints a very different
picture of Neanderthals than we had up
until I mean just a few years ago we we
know now
um to take Justin neanderthals as one
example that that neanderthals far from
being this really backward um slow
dim-witted group we're actually doing
extremely capable things and making
making objects and artifacts and and
Innovative Innovative tools and they
were extremely well adapted
um and that we had a very long period of
overlap with neanderthals um and groups
of Neanderthals in Eurasia
um and and places like Europe and um the
genetic Legacy that we have tells us
increasingly that who we are today is
really part of the legacy of these
interactions that we experienced in the
past and in fact Tom as I understand it
the the latest dating indicates that
neanderthals are engaging in these
complex activities often
tens of thousands of years before Homo
sapiens even arrived on the scene in
Europe so so before we go any further
I'd like to share with our viewers some
of the more extraordinary sites that
that you and your colleagues have been
studying
one of the most evocative Neanderthal
sites has been found deep inside a cave
in brunikel in Southwest France somebody
and more likely a whole group of
somebody's working together arranged
hundreds of charred stalagmites into two
large circles this could have been the
site of ritual shamanic or funeral
ceremonies around 175
000 years ago since at that time
neanderthals were the only hominids in
Europe that is all but certain they were
the ones who designed and built these
remarkably complex structures
in yet another cave in Spain a set of
Neanderthal teeth tells the story of a
young male suffering from an abscess and
a stomach bug his tartar suggests the
unfortunate fellow was self-medicating
with among other things chamomile fungus
containing penicillin and Poplar bark
which contains salicylic acid the
anti-inflammatory and aspirin
neanderthals also had style these pieces
of refined looking bone jewelry belonged
to a Chic Neanderthal in France around
42 000 years ago
more than 64 000 years ago sensitive
Neanderthal souls in Spain were making
cave art the stencil of a child's hand
and these abstract patterns were made
twenty thousand years before Homo
sapiens arrived that was a long time
before another Spanish artist from the
same region Pablo Picasso made a name
for himself
not bad considering that when the first
Neanderthal fossils were found it was
suggested the species be named
homostupidus and if all you homo sapiens
out there are starting to feel
competitive you can relax these
Paleolithic prodigies Are All in the
Family
when Homo sapiens showed up in Europe
and Asia neanderthals co-existed with
them for several thousand years before
dying out enough time for some of them
to meet up and on occasion become
intimate
we know this because Noble Prize winners
fonte pebo and his team have pioneered a
new field called paleogenetics
among their accomplishments they were
able to sequence the Neanderthal genome
when they did we learned among other
things that today modern humans of
European or Asian descent on average are
genetically one to two percent
neanderthal
now Vivion that I gather is your field
the relatively young discipline of
paleogenetics sequencing the Genome of
ancient humans which I have to say seems
like an extraordinary thing to be able
to do and in some cases from
just a few slivers of bone I mean how
much can we learn from such genetic data
the most basic way that we can sort of
look at DNA of ancient hominins and
other organisms doesn't have to be
hominins is that we would take a bone or
tooth and and we would drill a little
hole in it to recover some powder
and then we can extract the DNA that is
released into a solution by using
chemicals that affect both the organic
and the inorganic parts of the bone and
that tells us what was essentially the
genetic makeup of these ancient humans
we can tell the genetic sex of course
but we can also see which population
that these individuals were derived from
both on the maternal line that we know
from a small part of our genome called
the mitochondrial DNA but also
genome-wide from both parents
um we can tell about issues of
adaptation for example genetic
adaptation to different environments we
can talk about kinship and social
structure in ancient groups
um and we'll I'm sure talk later on
about sort of mating and movement
between populations and when they met
and the um and and intermixed so how how
long can genetic material last in an
ancient sample it's very dependent on
the environment
so if you're looking in permafrost
the oldest DNA sequence that has been
retrieved so far it's actually a study
that came out just a few months ago
comes from Mammoth remains that are of
over 1 million years ago
um but that's in permafrost where
essentially the samples are in a freezer
for the last million years going outside
of permafrost in more temperate climates
the oldest DNA we have so far is both
bare DNA and human DNA coming from a
cave in Spain called Sima de los huesos
and these remains are dated to about 430
000 years ago
and this is sort of the extreme
um of what we can so far or what has
been done so far
um outside of permafrost I now work um
in the area of the Levant where outside
temperatures are quite warm and it's a
problem for DNA preservation uh we are
very happy when we can find a spot that
is more than 10 000 years old you've
gone beyond
extracting organic material from from
Bones and are also studying it in in
just the dirt right in in the sediment
at some archaeological site
how is that going and is this is this an
idea that when first put forward people
thought was crazy or is it one that
people like yeah that that that that
might work when I got interested into
looking into this to try and look for
ancient hominin DNA it was considered
one of the crazy projects because we all
we thought all of us that it would be
too hard to tell apart contamination
from um from ancient DNA particularly
when we were working with human DNA
which is of course as ancient and modern
has a lot of similarities
um and so this idea of being able to
take I would say a soup of DNA that you
extract from a sediment so this sediment
sample can contain DNA from plants and
from microbes and from different animals
and to be able to say something about
that population it's Neanderthal it's
Denise of and it's something else
um no it was definitely definitely
supposed to be a crazy project but we
did a pilot study and we found that it
does work when you can go to his
archaeological site and Sample tens or
even hundreds of samples and look for
changes in the human populations through
sometimes tens and even hundreds of
thousands of years of History just by
looking at elements so that's I think to
me very exciting yeah it sounds hugely
exciting we'll talk about some of the
implications in just a moment let me
turn to to Becky now there's this
I don't know almost canonical story that
many of us have been told at least those
of us on the outside of the field that
you know there is an evolutionary record
in which species evolve they diverge
they Branch off and and one of those
branches over the course of evolutionary
history ultimately resulted in us right
I think that's sort of a familiar story
that that many people have heard
I gather there's growing evidence and
your perspective is that that metaphor
that framework really needs to be
retired in some sense or at least
updated in a significant way to include
the kinds of of mixings that we're going
to talk about more that we've already
heard referenced to just give us a sense
of where where you come down on on the
right way of thinking about things I
come down firmly in the braided stream
kind of space so instead of there being
just a branching and one thing leads
through you have quite a lot more
interaction and you have mergers through
hybridization that results in gene flow
that itself doesn't just bring things
together it can also be the producer of
novelty and new variation so gene flow
if you can just uh give us a sense of
what that term means because I know it's
going to be vital to what we're talking
about
yeah so we've kind of used these terms a
bit Loosely sometimes and and in fact
the term that you'll see or you'll hear
more often is hybridization essentially
hybridization is the act right you have
organisms coming together and mating so
they're hybridizing when it comes to
actually looking at a skeletal remain
are there telltale signs of some kind of
hybridization event in the past yes
there are and that's some of the stuff
I've been doing which is looking at
saying okay let me look at other hybrids
let me look at other organisms other
mammals primates
um wildebeest all sorts of things and
can we see what that signature of
hybridization looks like in the skeleton
so that we can use those analogs to then
look at the fossil record and see if we
see those same kinds of signatures we
can look again at the human fossil
record and see some evidence for it are
there any examples you can give just a
sense of what sort of specific things
are the signatures
sure I can get example
um so I've done a lot of work in baboons
and when you look at baboon hybrids what
they show is that when you have two very
different slightly different depending
on what what groups of baboons you're
looking at genomes that are coming
together but they're different enough
that they cause developmental I want to
say almost glitches if you will the
little um lines in your face where your
bones come together for example or a
suture or on your skull
um extra teeth
rotated teeth so little small signatures
that allow us to look into the fossil
record and identify and this is
important individuals who might be a
hybrid and so when you use the word
glitch what comes to mind for me is this
kind of folk myth that by bringing
together different animals different
species somehow you create I don't know
frankenstein-like Monster structures
has that
View
which obviously comes from a very coarse
reading of how the world actually works
but has that view impacted the degree to
which the possibility of these
hybridizations has been accepted by the
community absolutely yeah you know I I
think that the community of the human
evolution Community more broadly okay
anthropology in particular has been
relatively slow to uptake this for a
number of reasons but the primary one is
probably because the work on
hybridization the good work on
hybridization was actually being done
um primarily in plant biology and it was
kind of easy for people to wrap their
heads around the idea of plants
hybridizing I mean we hybridize plants
all the time and then it moved to to
animal biology but that was only you
know sort of 30 years ago-ish where we
started to get a real flourishing of our
understanding of hybridization and
animal animal biology and so that field
was on top of it if you will but that
literature
um never really it never really got into
paleoanthropology and human evolution so
it wasn't really accessible in that way
and on top of that as you said we tend
to people tend to have this kind of idea
that hybridization is bad that if you
have hybrids it's going to produce an
offspring that's going to be mutant or
if not mutant at least um infertile
right and that that essentially wouldn't
go anywhere and what all these studies
coming out of plant and animal biology
have shown is that yeah that can happen
you know sometimes you have infertile
individuals sometimes you have reduced
fertility sometimes you have
um lineages that come together and merge
essentially so it you know it basically
collapses everything but sometimes you
can have the evolution of new species
through hybridization that are different
enough from their parents that they
maybe are adaptively different can
succeed in different environments than
their parents could sometimes you get
the evolution of novelty in these new
groups through new combinations of
traits and these this kind of novelty
and speciation is the um it's the the
productive force of gene flow and of
hybridization that hadn't been given
attention before yeah we'll look at some
examples in in just a moment but Sheila
let me turn to you now your focus has
also been in morphology but as I
understand it you've also taken a more
what might be called a holistic approach
I mean we heard from Tom about
radiocarbon dating other methods Vivion
in terms of a genetic approach Becky in
terms of maybe changing the Paradigm
where we don't view it as just a
tree-like structure but rather I think
he described it as these these blending
streams I sort of like that metaphor a
lot so what's your view is there is
there a new approach that really needs
to take root in the field for the kind
of progress that we all want to have
happen to take place
yes my
frustration has always been the existing
models that I have to put my work in so
I'm very interested in middle and late
pleistocene evolution in Asia
um but the interpretive Frameworks
available to me have been language that
that just doesn't make sense to me so
um you know the origin of modern humans
and Extinction and um
and the idea that homo erectus went
extinct and was replaced I felt like I
was doing like retroactive racism by
saying okay these are pure and these are
us and these are um other Asia wasn't
just this recipient of evolutionary
innovations that came out of Africa or
even these evolutionary Novelties that
came from Europe right it wasn't
unidirectional that there was um in that
the gene flow was was moving both ways
and that um you know maybe some of the
specimens that we're looking at in
Central Asia or Southwest Asia or
Eastern Europe
um have also been shaped by gene flow
from the East to understand if there's
yet another Cranium that was found
that's called homolongi or Dragon man
this one was discovered in Northeast
China and I've read that some of those
who led the study I think it was Chris
Stringer of the British museum have
suggested that maybe homolonga is the
closest relative to us in terms of the
Paleolithic family tree so does that
strengthen your view that we really need
to think locally about our lineage is
that another piece of evidence in favor
of that perspective
um that's a really good question and I
would actually I make my answer might be
unexpected to you which is no it doesn't
strengthen it because you know this
um comes back to
um some of the work I do which really
interrogates
the language that we're using right I
don't subscribe immediately to something
being a new species just because it's
been named as such one of the things
that I think drives this idea that this
is like us it really conforms to our
understanding of what modern humans look
like based on what what really what
Europeans look like right and so it
doesn't have a big brain does it have a
globular head does it have smaller teeth
and so rather than actually look at the
fossil record in the early late
pleistocene or the late middle
pleistocene and say well what were the
patterns of variation around the world
at that time and let that be what
defines us we take this type and then we
search for it around the world there's a
very fascinating correlation between
major climatic events that happen that
really shape China and the Chinese
landscape
at the time period that all of these
fossils such as the um the longy
specimen and some of the other things
that were recently published from the
site of shuchang and hualongdong
um that
are at least sort of what Becky you know
works on
um evidence that that there were things
that would have relaxed
um the climatic barriers and allowed for
gene flow and you know could that be why
we're seeing some of these new
morphologies at this time period around
300 000 years it's a period of
incredible warming and
um and stability which really
facilitates populations coming together
and does any of this have an impact on
when we should imagine Homo sapiens
having arrived in Asia
do those dates need to be revamped
to be revamped is
the idea that homo sapiens evolution is
going to be this clean event and not a
process Homo sapiens evolution is a
process and so we can't name it as being
a moment in time and an arrival in
another place and so building on that
thought Sheila I'd like to turn now to
another set of discoveries that have
challenged our previous View of early
human history in Asia
we've already talked about some
surprising insights involving
neanderthals in Europe before Homo
sapiens arrived on the other side of the
continent discovers in the altai
mountains of Siberia give us a new
picture of what was happening there and
roughly the same time period Tom and
Vivion you have been deeply involved in
this but before we dive in let's share
some of the story with our audience
this remote region on the border between
Russia and China is the site of the cave
of denisova
2010 the team who had sequenced the
Neanderthal Gene made a stunning
announcement that radically changed the
picture of early human history
they had discovered an entirely new
unknown group of ancient humans
remarkably the initial evidence came
from a mere sliver of Pinky bone its
nuclear DNA revealed it belonged to a
young girl who lived between 52 and 76
000 years ago the previously unknown
archaic humans were named denisovans
after the cave where the pinky had been
found
[Music]
the Denise Evans like neanderthals turn
out to be some of our long-lost
relatives their DNA shows up today
primarily in populations across Asia and
Oceana but Denise him and jeans have
been found in people as far away as the
Americas
when Tom hayam and a team of Russian and
Australian researchers sifted through
fragments of prehistoric trash in the
Denise van cave They concluded Denise
Evans lived there as early as 200 000
years ago and maybe earlier these
previously unknown relatives of ours
were making jewelry and tools and living
in this remote corner of Asia for
hundreds of thousands of years before
Homo sapiens arrived on the continent
but Denise events are not the only
archaic humans who lived in that cave
other bone fragments found them revealed
they may have shared it for a time with
neanderthals starting around 170
000 years ago at first it was unclear
whether or how the two groups interacted
then in 2019 Tom hayam and Vivian Sloan
were involved in another astonishing
discovery
carefully searching a bag of prehistoric
rubble from the cave a member of Tom's
team Came Upon yet another finger bone
fragment less than two and a half
centimeters long
Vivian salon's DNA analysis of this
fossil made headlines
she found it was that of a 13 year old
girl whose father was denisovan but
whose mother was Neanderthal they named
her Denny the fruit of a liaison and
that Paleolithic Penthouse some 90 000
years ago Denny is the first fossil of a
first generation human hybrid ever
discovered
so this all kind of has the makings of I
don't know you might think of it as a a
prehistoric Thriller right a kind of
enticing detective story if you will
you've got these remote caves in Siberia
in Tibet you got layers of human
habitation where groups we have
identified as different species and we
can come back to that they're living
together apparently they're let's say
it's sleeping together you've got a
trail of genetic hybridization that
reaches across the Pacific right Vivian
and Thomas begin though with the
discovery
itself Tom can you talk about your work
so the work that um that I and my team
have been involved in really stems from
um a conversation and a meeting that
took place at Denise of the cave itself
between
um several colleagues as it happens my
wife and my co-researcher Katarina duka
and I and we were thinking um over the
course of several days whilst we're at
the site of this tremendous problem at
Denise Denise of a cave has been
excavated since the early 1980s and
there are thousands and thousands of
bones that have been dug out of that
site
and of course they um they provided in
some cases these tiny human remains
these very very small pieces of bone
that have the great benefit of having
lots and lots of DNA and most of them
you could fit the bones of the denisons
from that cave on one on on your hand
and most of the bones more than 95 of
all of the bones excavated at the site
are tiny fragments that we simply don't
know
um the identification of we don't know
which species they are they could be
Mammoth bones hyena bones you know
cattle bones we have no idea but amongst
them lurk some undoubted human remains
human bones are of the kind that have
already been identified by some of the
archaeologists there so we were thinking
well how could we take advantage of this
tremendous source of information this
tremendous uh preserved DNA Legacy how
can we find these human remains and so
we fixed upon this recently then
recently discovered technique of zoo Ms
so um zooms or zooms it's um it's an
acronym that is used to describe a
really exciting new technique which
takes advantage of the fact that in
different animals and different species
of animals there are very slight
differences in the proteins and the
peptides that make up the collagen part
of the bone collagen and proteins
generally have a fantastic advantage
over DNA in some respects in that they
survive for much much longer so many
more millions of years than the um than
the DNA that Viviana was talking about
before and we thought well what we could
do would be to take a whole bunch of
these bones take them back to the lab
and just analyze every single one of
them and see whether or not any of them
have the fingerprint the protein
fingerprint of of a homina day of the
the broader Human family and Samantha
Brown who was the student that took on
the project in our lab in Oxford she
worked very hard to take small samples
from each of the bones and number
1227 gave us the characteristic five
hits on these peptides that told us this
was a bone of of a human but what human
we we couldn't tell so this this little
fragment
um like like how little is little are we
talking about here yeah well we're
talking 2.4 centimeters um so you can
see that it is um it is really small and
it's completely nondescript you would
never know that it's a bone of a human
it could be from anything but the other
peptide sequence told us that it was uh
it was from uh from one of the Human
family
um but uh that is as far as we could get
with the uh with the peptide with the
peptides we really needed the DNA
extracted to tell us exactly what it was
but yes it's a tiny bone nondescript and
from a from a bag of bones of thousands
of bones that we can't tell apart so
once you've found it I mean did you put
that in a vault or something how do you
ensure that that little fragment uh
stays with you so we put it into a
special um yellow briefcase that that
Sam used to used to carry around it's in
my office here
yeah
no no I'm serious yeah I still have it
here it's the bonus there I'm going to
take it back to to Russia to um to to
give it back to my Russian colleagues
because um they store all of the human
material from the um from the Denise of
the site there but I just haven't been
able to get there for the last few years
so
um because of covert obviously so um it
will be repatriated to um to its friends
uh in Duke that is good to hear so
Vivian you took it from there so you got
a hold of this little fragment of bone
and it was up to you to try to use these
DNA techniques so what happened
so yes I was lucky to be at the right
time with the right place in Leipzig
where Sam arrived with her little yellow
suitcase with the bone in it
um and so we sampled it together and the
in the clean room uh at the max plant
Institute in Leipzig and we extracted
the DNA it got sort of the official name
of denisova 11th or the catalog number
uh of the 11th human remain from
denisova but as Tom can tell you they
had already nicknamed it Denny in the
lab and so uh Denny is what we often uh
call her something very unexpected
happened is that we found that she
matched both the Neanderthal variants
and the Denise of invariants in almost
equal proportions so we had found this
individual that had both Neanderthal and
Denise of An ancestry in almost equal
extents
um were you shocked today were you
shocked about this were you surprised by
that result could it have been just the
result of contamination yeah so that was
actually my first thought was oh wow did
I do in the lab did I mixed samples up
like how is that possible
um and for for quite a while I was very
unsure as to what the signal um was due
to
um I do remember that the first time
that I presented it in a lab meeting and
I was like hey people look I have this
half and half and people were sort of
throwing around the word hybrid as a
joke because nobody thought this was
possible that we would actually come
across a mixed Offspring and make a sort
of a mixed Neanderthal denisovan and I
was certain that there was something
wrong that there was something some
mixture happening in the lab some some
human error and so we went back to the
Bone and we sampled it again and again
and again and a total of six different
times six different experiments uh sort
of from the beginning all the way till
the sequencing
um and again and again and again we saw
this this analytical picture of half
nanitol half denisovan and just to be
sure this wasn't happening with other
bones that we were working on in
parallel so it wasn't some kind of
technical problem that was affecting
sort of everything we're working on this
is really only this individual
and then we had okay so then you know
you start believing it happens over and
over again so it does seem that this
individual has both Neanderthal and
Denise of An ancestry we saw that the
scenario that is best supported is the
fact that she had one parent of each
group and so
since uh we know that she has the
mitochondrial DNA so what's coming from
the mom that is neanderthal-like we can
then infer the family tree of this 90
000 year old individual and say she was
the daughter of an anatol mother and a
Denise even father wow so that's that's
an astounding Discovery to
stumbled upon this first generation
blending of these two lineages but but
Becky when you heard of this work I mean
what was your response because I gather
you've been thinking the necessity of
bringing hybridization into the story
for a long time were you like thrilled
by this or like yeah I already know that
what's so surprising about that
um I wasn't surprised I was uh happy
that that uh F1 hybrid had finally been
found it didn't it didn't Shock Me In in
any way I have to confess but you know
part of the reason it didn't shock me is
I think we've been seeing over the last
decade of these genetic studies is that
um hybrids aren't all that uncommon
right I think the issue was would you
ever find a first generation one which
hadn't been found before and eventually
you're going to find a first generation
one
um yeah so I guess it wasn't a huge
shock um but if I can speak a little bit
to this this hybrids aren't all that
uncommon thing
um I think one of the things that really
that that stands out for me in this work
is that and I think it's amazing it's
wonderful to find these genetic studies
but you know
as Tom was saying you know we don't
really know very much about what they
look like so we don't know much of
anything in terms of morphology we don't
know if some other fossils that we don't
have genetic evidence for might actually
be Dennis events so Sheila Becky made
reference to the fact that she's not a
great fan of this biological
classification of of species and uh I
don't want to put words in Becky's map I
suspect part of that comes from when I
was in in 10th grade in Mrs Goldberg's
biology class we learned that species
were those groups that could not produce
fertile offspring right and yet we seem
to be talking about Denise event
neanderthals coming together and and
presumably yielding hybrids that can
actually reproduce so so is it useful to
talk about these two lineages as
distinct species and and moreover if
they're all living together in this in
this communal cave how should we think
about that part of the evolutionary past
the study of living human variation has
kind of gone through a healthy
post-racial Reckoning
and yet we're still talking about
ancient human variation as branches on
trees
so
um at a minimum I think it it prevents
us from getting at really you know
meaningful answers about evolution
and at its worst I think it's it can be
dangerous because the um
the people who live in these regions
um
I think
are kind of getting treated as branches
on a tree
and that can have really you know really
problematic implications yep can I jump
in yeah please Becky when we when these
scenarios are painted that break break
human ancestors into different groups
one of the things that's been done is
that you know one group is adaptively
superior to the other or you know better
in some way so they've adapted in
different ways and and one is more
advanced in terms of their intellect
more advanced in terms of their tools
more advances all of these things and I
think that's what Sheila's I'm speaking
to in terms of reifying these very
problematic ideas that we've eliminated
in living people but we continue to
perpetuate when we're looking at the
fossil record and why that's really
important is to me the fact that you
have
or all the time we you know we look at
something look you get oh hybridization
oh there's another one hybridization oh
another one in human evolution actually
it tells me something behaviorally it
tells me that these groups of people
were coming together often and that
their behavior
wasn't really all that different you
know and their culture wasn't really all
that different because if it had been I
promise you we wouldn't be seeing this
sort of frequency of individuals who
have the who have these signatures of
hybridization in the genome Tom I'd like
to hear your views on this too do you
view the Denise events as a a different
lineage or what the right word is a
different group
um should we jettison the idea of
thinking of them as different species
Tom what's your take on that
yeah I think it it's a really
complicated uh area and I I get I get uh
uncomfortable talking about it to an
extent so
um I think the reason that we have these
difficulties is that in terms of
evolutionary time we don't have to go
back millions of years to find the last
common ancestor of these groups it's
comparatively recent right I mean if
you're looking at neanderthals and Homo
sapiens let's say you know you're
looking about half a million years and
for for Denise Evans and the anatols
comparatively brief at times and that
means that enough time and separation
geographical separation hasn't accrued
hasn't gone by that when they meet once
more from their geological geographical
separation that they aren't able to uh
produce
offspring that then can they can can
they gone themselves to have a healthy
Offspring so
um of course we're going to have
problems discussing this species concept
and it doesn't work as as has been
pointed out in this particular context
labels are important um though and I
think I still think that when we're
talking about
um let's say groups of Neanderthals and
groups of denisimons that these values
have these labels have value because we
can see physical differences between
these groups we can see the morphology
um is very clearly uh different and I
think for that reason they're important
to maintain and to keep but I agree with
everyone that the species um the the
species discussion is uh is extremely
and exceedingly complex
um but to give you an example well you
know when we're looking at Denise Evans
and Neanderthals we know
from the from the from the
archaeological evidence in the fossil
record and the genetic evidence that
these are groups that are largely
speaking in different parts of the
continent of Eurasia they're in the West
in the case of Neanderthals they're
predominantly in the east in the case of
um of denisovans and when Denise Evans
and nettles met on occasion they for
sure had viable Offspring um whereas in
the east in the west I should say in the
Neanderthal
um uh dominated part of of Eurasia we
don't get any Denise even DNA in that
part of the world at all and so there's
a degree of separation and so using the
the available data I know there's a a
portrait that's been painted kind of
artist rendition of what this lineage
might look like we can show it up on the
screen
how accurate of an image do you guys
consider this to be and and and how
useful is it or is it not useful to sort
of conjecture what things look like in
the past based upon this very important
but minimal data yeah so this is not
based on the DNA code itself and it's
based on inferences of what one would
expect to see
when you get a specific type of
regulation on the DNA versus another
um I think it's very useful it is in
some ways inferences that would have to
be validated against the fossil record
and against genetic genetic data but I
think it's very useful because it gives
predictions as to what denisovans looked
like and then we can take the fossil
record that we know of and possibly new
fossils that we found and try to see
okay does that fit into our expectations
or whether Denise of and what would look
like and it's certainly better than what
we had so far which was three teeth a
piece of a bone and then half a jaw so
anything more than that is more than
welcome I mean if we're walking around
at the appropriate moment in the place
to see and we bump into the nearest
Denise event is is is that the image
that you imagine of the person that will
encounter that they'll look like that
I think that that is a fun inference but
it's impossible not to recognize that
that's filtered through
um so many of our present-day cultural
lenses about what
um people look like and so you know if
you if you look at the
um about you know the very popular image
of like an ape and then a stooped man
and then a you know an Iraq human
um they're always brown skinned and
dark-haired until the last person right
and so
um so you know there's obviously
um interesting science that's being
brought to bear into these
reconstructions but ultimately
reconstructions are
um are interpretive do any of you have
any any even just a a gut guess about
whether language use was part of the
behavioral repertoire of Neanderthals
anyone want to go on a limb online I'll
make a guess yeah please I'll make a
guess thank you
from reading so much if they couldn't
communicate
um it just doesn't make sense
um and and speaking to what Tom was just
saying I mean we also know that Gene
lineages don't you know diverge the way
humans do and Gene lineages don't mean
species necessarily so we have to be
kind of careful in that in that space as
well I guess I'm I'm a little bit
uncomfortable
um with the way that the conversation
has shifted here and and I'll tell you
why it's because
it's it's sort of going back into this
idea that we can find
relatively pure groups
and the other is messy kind of in the
middle so like the Western neanderthals
for example we know we call them classic
neanderthals there's no evidence for
interbreeding they do look quite
distinctly different but that's not the
case when we get you know into other
parts of the world where neanderthals
and and
um other human groups were overlapping
with each other so I I think I'm echoing
Sheila's previous concern that we don't
go back to this idea
and it's something we do it's something
we it's something we've been doing
forever go back to this idea of of just
seeking out
differences between these groups rather
than trying to understand all of them in
terms of this incredible variation
because that's what's happening you're
getting gene flow between these
different groups and what it's doing is
it's contributing new variation to who
we are today it's if you will
it's the fuel of evolution right it is
allowing us to adapt and to move into
migrate into lots of different spaces
but it all still resides in us today and
so if nothing else it's it's actually
um it's a it's a positive force but I
think if you think of a scenario where
we have
um much much lower population density
than we have today right really very
very low population density you're going
to have groups of these ancestors
um spread across this which means just
by definition you know we're social
animals so we live in in Pockets within
that
um because they're so dispersed on the
landscape and because people migrate to
get new resources and for other reasons
you're going to have differences that
are due to chance you're going to have
to have differences that are due to
Adaptive differences within groups
because they've settled in different
regions of the world
um and then they're going to come
together every so often and they're
going to exchange genes and that's the
pattern that we're seeing it's actually
reflecting a low density and we haven't
talked much about genetic drift and
chance effects but it's reflecting a low
density of people on the landscape gives
them opportunities to diversify but that
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
meaningfully different right in in a
meaningful way it just means that
they're different because we are too at
the end of the day so in thinking about
the various human lineages Vivian should
we envision that the Neanderthals went
extinct is that the right way of
thinking about it
so I think that
people talked about neanderthals not so
much about the new students we didn't
know about but about neanderthals going
extinct because the type of stone tools
that they make or they made at some
point disappears from the fossil record
and at some point the skeletons that can
be attributed to them also you just
don't find them anymore and so from this
came the idea that they they completely
went extinct now one of the actually
first insights that came out of
sequencing a neanderthal genome was the
fact that there is still Neanderthal DNA
in people living today so anyone living
today that is not of sub-Saharan African
ancestry carries between one to maybe
three percent of their genome coming
from Neanderthals
and so if you think about this like that
then you know perhaps the NFL didn't go
extinct in a way they still live within
us so also for sequencing uh the
denisovan genome and then comparing that
genome to people living today we know
that there's DNA of Denise events in
present-day populations so if you go in
Oceania in some parts of Papa for
example you have people living today
that have up to six percent of the
genome coming from Denise events that's
quite a lot
um and we do find also denisov and DNA
in in other parts of Asia and so again
in some ways they just didn't disappear
they still parts of them live in us and
still affect our genomes today and I
heard and I don't know you can correct
me if if this is just you know one of
those urban legends that you find on
Tick Tock or Twitter but that that the
way we in the modern era right now
respond say to various viruses like
covid even is potentially impact did by
some of the Neanderthal DNA is that is
that real is that nonsense yes it is
real it is real and it's actually I
think one of the interesting aspects of
looking at Neanderthal DNA and a Denise
of an DNA is that we can still think how
does it impact our our own health in our
own world today and covet is a great
example
um that sort of came out of this
unfortunate pandemic that hit us all
um is that by comparing genetic variants
that
affect the susceptibility to this to
develop uh Covenant and severe covid-19
symptoms it was found that there is a
specific genetic variant on chromosome 3
where people living today if they have
the Neanderthal type of this variant
there are more likely to develop severe
symptoms of covid-19 if they catch the
virus and so as I said this means that
the neonatal DNA in us or in some of us
still affects us today and quite
interestingly sort of a few months later
with more analyzes coming up than
another variant in another part of a
genome was found and this time if you
have the Neanderthal DNA it's actually
protecting yuke from coven 19. so
depending on bit on the lottery of
genetics you know it may be good and it
may be bad to have Neanderthal DNA so so
Tom Becky you know with all this very
recent work that's suggesting these
interesting New Perspectives coming from
the fines uh in China what what do you
think the the Gestalt could be going
forward in terms of thinking about the
structure of our evolutionary past is it
is it more a give and take across the
world do we need to get rid of this old
image as Sheila was saying where we're
kind of imagining things flowing in One
Direction not the other
yeah I mean I do I I I think that
you know
The Narrative view that was introduced
in the beginning the idea that you have
one group of humans those that one group
of humans
um it becomes you know more capable
becomes uh conquerors becomes better
adapted to Being Human
has all sorts of genetic changes that
make them human leaves the continent
conquers conquers conquers conquers
conquers right and takes over the world
that was essentially the Out of Africa
narrative such as it was and that is
that's pretty much demolished right it's
not a thing so I guess the question that
that we have going forward is
is the noon what does this new narrative
look like in detail so I think we're
slowly it's like a slow progress moving
away from this very um simplistic very
replacement very unidirectional model
and I suspect I mean if I'm going to
kind of put myself out there
um that as we get more and more and more
information and goodness it wouldn't it
be nice to get more um genetic
information from Africa as well
um that's deeper in time that we're
going to get exactly this a much more
complicated picture of
um movement that it's going to be much
more
I would say evenly distributed uh then
the picture that we're getting now but
you know we'll kind of have to see we'll
kind of have to see where this where
this takes us so Becca you've already
emphasized your view that the older
canonical Out of Africa approach has
been in your words demolished and is it
more just there's a blending and because
of that some new hybrid emerges and the
whole notion of going extinct may be
itself a too simplistic way of thinking
about things
that's a difficult question to answer
you know I
I I'm going to say something first that
I've been wanting to say and that is
that um
variation
produces Evolution right Evolution
produces variation this braided stream
if you will of people has resulted in
increasing variation so the the species
that we have today has a lot more
variation in it genetically than it
would have had if some of those things
hadn't happened bits and pieces were
picked up through and kept and some
things were lost and some things were
kept and they're put together in New in
different ways but we're very variable
and that gives us um resilience right
resilience in the face of change
resilience in the face of new
environments and so something goes
extinct and that's not really what we're
seeing because it doesn't none of this
fully goes away in the human record it's
just producing this increased variation
that has resulted in in who we are today
and then to speak to something else that
you mentioned um you know
and you were talking about these new
fossils and new fossils being found in
different parts of the world and how
exciting that is and it's adding to our
knowledge of the evolution of our
lineage and of humans generally where
people are looking matters
who's doing the looking matters who has
the money to do the looking matters
um who's shaping the choices and the
narratives matters and we've had a long
history certainly in perioanthropology a
very specific groups of people out there
and asking the questions and doing it in
very specific kinds of ways and often
marginalizing others or simply not
involving them at all and so for me
that's kind of the most exciting
um path that we have going forward is
this ability to start to forge real
relationships with people on the ground
and start to have conversations that
that fit the global movement that we're
having about you know why are we so
interesting why are we so diverse and
you know how can we learn more about
um how we became these sort of complex
diverse humans that we are today so jump
on off in that one final question
I'm often asked the question about life
in other worlds I suspect you all are as
well and and my view has always been
that with the great number of planets
and the great number of stars out there
I think most of us have an intuition
that life has a good chance of being out
there somewhere in the cosmos that often
I follow that by saying but life is one
thing an intelligent life is something
completely different because intelligent
life when you look at Planet Earth my
previous View was there's like one
single example of it and by intelligent
I mean intelligence the level where you
can build a radio telescope you can
build a rocket ship should we view that
intelligence itself has arisen many
times on this planet in many different
places and therefore would that perhaps
suggest that intelligence is more of a
natural outgrowth of The evolutionary
process as opposed to some singular
event that bequeath to the world called
Homo sapiens final words on that thought
when we start with Tom yeah um that's a
really uh that's a really good question
and I think the answer's got to be yes
because
um if we look again harking back to
um some of our um some of the wider
Human family the most well-known on
neanderthals
um so you know we we we we lose
neanderthals we think somewhere around
40 000 years ago so between 40 000 years
ago and today that's a long tract of
time neanderthals no longer had the um
had the possibilities of going through
the climatic and environmental changes
that we did undergoing the selection
pressures that we did
um you know responding to to various
changes and and adaptation uh that that
we did and so uh running the tape again
I don't have too much doubt that
neanderthals could have got onto a very
similar type of evolutionary trajectory
that we did Denise Evans we know
virtually nothing about in terms of
their archeology G but we have as I say
we have this evidence that they were
probably quite capable too it's still
emerging and still controversial but if
we accept
um that Denise Evans made it to
um Island Southeast Asia or east of
Wallace's line they must have had a
degree of technology to be able to do
that you can't just swim across those
gaps you have to have some kind of
Maritime based technology we know that
hominins that were much earlier than
that and older than that did too you
know the ancestors of homophoresiensis
on Flores and Homo luzonensis on on the
Philippines and so yes I think it's it
seems to me that uh it's more than
likely that this type of ability and
this type of intelligence that we
formally only saw in see in us could
have Arisen more than once yes Sheila
thoughts on intelligence and number of
times it's Arisen on planet Earth so I
mean intelligence is a cultural
construct
um and but I get what you mean right you
know the the idea that we are
um you know we are the only species on
Earth that turns the microscope on
ourselves right and asks our own
questions about ourselves
um but I think it's uh we we cannot
possibly Trace that back in the um false
and archaeological record without some
of our own cultural biases and so
um you know historically we talk about
behavioral modernity in these very um in
these very Western European terms and so
we look for art and we look for
adornment and we look for you know and
and we and those are what colonialists
look for when they were trying to say
that this civilization was you know
civilized or not
and so you know to Tom's point there are
other ways to express extremely complex
and Abstract capabilities Maritime
technology and um all of the
implications of of climatology you know
understanding astronomy and
um and climatology all the things that
are required for for doing
um any sort of Maritime activities
then
um then I think that we shouldn't assume
that it start it it is
um the Hallmark of homo sapiens because
there's just so much evidence of these
skill sets that
um that we would consider abstract
thinking that are
um present simply by the presence of a
fossil record in Indonesia at you know
one million years ago Vivion the uh wide
birth of Intelligence on planet Earth
yeah so I think it's also important to
think about the fact that we're not the
only intelligent species out there right
we're not the only ones who make tools
we're not the only ones who are capable
of changing our environment in order to
adapt to it I think we are shifting from
a way that we used to look at
neanderthals researchers looked or used
to do look at neanderthals as these sort
of incapable a bit stupid uh human
beings that sort of were too stupid to
survive and we certainly I think most of
archaeologists today and and people
studying the past with the degree that
this is no longer what we think and we
think there was a lot of exchanges of
culture and exchanges not only of genes
uh between these populations and that it
is not only the intelligence that sort
of drove us to to still be around today
Becky you've got the final word
intelligence on Earth how widespread it
may have Arisen and if you're willing
intelligence through the cosmos all I
can think of is the octopus
yeah oh yeah I mean no I mean really
right yeah the the problem with defining
intelligence and this is a classic
classic thing in primatology is that you
know for for so long we Define
intelligence through the lens of of
ourselves and through the lens of
whoever's whoever is making those
definitions is filtering okay so can we
measure them by us can we measure can a
can a chimpanzee
um Flint nap tools that are just like us
okay yeah they can but can they do it on
their own would they come up with the
idea right so we're always filtering
these things through our understanding
of our type of intelligence so I think
that's one point but more broadly to
your to your question here
um
you know
yes all of these hominins they've
they've been um constructing their
niches for hundreds of thousands
millions of years and moving into
different places so they all had a very
high level of intelligence and I would
definitely
um
absolutely I'm sure there are other
intelligent forms of life do they look
like us no probably not and different
planets are they
um intelligent in ways that we can't
understand it all because we crazy
humans like to filter things through our
way of thinking about intelligence in no
other way
um yeah they're probably really
different and we wouldn't maybe even be
able to recognize the intelligence when
we saw it
well thank you all for this fascinating
conversation on on the present
potentially the future of our
evolutionary past so thank you all for
joining us
[Music]
thank you